captured on security camera coming into
view this is convicted terrorist Sofia
shake in this other grainy image
she's the figure in the distance outside
London st. Paul's Cathedral its
September the 8th last year and she's
carrying out a hostile reconnaissance of
a building she intends to bomb inside
she sent this picture and message over
what's up to two others she believed
were helping her prepare the attack but
they were in fact undercover police
officers and just over a month after
scoping out one of London's most iconic
landmarks she was arrested the evidence
against her so overwhelming that she
confessed to everything during this
interview with detectives what was he
gonna do and you would have died as well
and the other people in there
[Music]
I thought it's my way to heaven
I thought that's my way for forgiveness
Sofia Sheikh had sworn allegiance to the
Islamic state terror group and planned a
similar attack to last year's Easter
Sunday bombings of churches in Sri Lanka
which killed more than 250 people
sapir Sheikh had very clear intent and
was absolutely committed to carry it out
she planned to plant a bomb in some
Paul's Cathedral during a busy time of
year she planned to leave a second bomb
at a nearby hotel and she also intended
to carry out a suicide bomb attack on
the London Underground as the plot
developed she handed over this pink
carrier bag and a rucksack to one of the
undercover detectives believing they
would construct the bombs and placed
them inside the bags for her primed and
ready to detonate investigators say she
fears Sheikh was no fantasies in handing
over her bag she expected them to return
full of explosives her stated aim to
kill as many people in the cathedral and
surrounding area as possible the 36 year
old Muslim convert was referred to the
prevent counter extremism program three
times as she became increasingly
radicalized she wasn't just talking to
talk she was definitely going to walk
the walk and therefore in no
circumstances it's absolutely right that
the authorities stepped in when they can
the changing terror threat is seeing
increasing numbers of extremists like
Sofia Sheikh reaching out to others
online staying one step ahead of them is
a massive challenge for authorities mark
white Sky News